each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so we're pleased to have here abram
hindle who is visiting us from he's
right now a postdoc at UC Davis with
Priam Davin boo and Jen dong-su and he
just recently got his PhD from Waterloo
working with my godfre and Rick Holt so
he's going to tell us about evidence
based software process recovery so take
it away are you Chris so thanks for
introduction so in this presentation
really what we're trying to do is we're
trying to take a theoretical diagram
that tries to explain maybe what
software development processes are and
what to expect inside of a project such
as this unified process diagram we're
trying to take the theoretical diagram
which never was concrete never was based
on actual data and extract it from a
real project and see what it actually
looks like based upon real data based
upon things that were recorded excuse me
so when we're talking about process
we're really talking about software
development processes and these range
from a wide variety of different kinds
of ideas what processes are so there is
the prescribed process so these would be
things like you have to follow tests
first we're following scrum we have
little scrubs in the morning or we use
story cards to define requirements
things like that many of these
prescribed processes are oftentimes
based upon formal processes things like
a waterfall model scrum XP unified
process anything like that but there's
also a whole set of sort of structured
behaviors which which are basically the
process of the project their ad hoc
processes these are basically things
that maybe as developers we've come to
an agreement that we're going to do we
didn't write it down the manager maybe
didn't specify it but it's sort of this
default behavior that we follow so the
process I'm talking about basically
cover the whole the whole range here
from the formal to the prescribe to the
ad hoc
so on the formal side there's actually
quite a few there's the waterfall model
which suggests how development could be
staggered where you have requirements
going into design and analysis going
into implementation eventually
deployment there's also iterative views
such as the spiral model where basically
you repeat this waterfall model a couple
of times over so you keep reiterating
over what you're doing and you have
basically multiple iterations then the
one we're mainly focusing on in this
presentation is the unified process and
the unified process is basically a model
where you have multiple disciplines and
you take part in these disciplines in
different proportions over time so this
diagram here the unified process diagram
this diagram will be coming back to
where it shows your disciplines like
your business modeling and then it shows
basically the amount of effort over the
existence of the project for that one
discipline so you can look at say one
release and see what the effort was
around at that time the proportion of
efforts okay so the world that we're
really dealing with if we want to
actually look at recover and extract
these processes is a world where
developers they want to follow a
software development process but they in
order to do so they have to exhibit
behavior and this behavior is exhibited
in order to fill a purpose or task which
compose a software development process
when they do something on the exhibit
behavior sometimes they produce evidence
lots of times this is lossy it doesn't
contain all the information but this
evidence can be used to suggest that the
underlying processes purposes tasks and
behaviors so the world that we're
dealing with that in order to actually
recover these processes is where we have
this evidence that was produced from the
behaviors they followed in order to
fulfill their processes fill their
purposes and then we basically have this
shadow world which we try to recover the
behavior recover the purposes and tasks
and use those behaviors and tests to
compose the underlying software
with processes and this all comes from
the evidence that developers produce but
the evidence is lossy so we don't see
everything like if they have a meeting
and its face to face maybe there's
minutes maybe there's not maybe they
have a talk in the hall we don't see
everything so for the rest of this
presentation I'm going to break it down
into basically behavior intents and
purposes and software development
processes and we've got four basically
different kinds of research that we
integrated for this work where we did
release patterns where we basically
looked at the the types of files changed
and the reasons why you would change
those files and so that del with
behavior and the process because we also
correlated it with how they acted around
release time was there a freeze things
like that and we had the large changes
study where we looked at the the purpose
behind large changes and tried to
categorize them by that we also use
topic analysis which help describe the
behavior and also help elicit some of
the intents and purposes followed by our
summary of the of the processes that
recovered unified process views and was
mostly about software development
processes okay so who would actually
want to see what was going on in a
project from process standpoint well
there's a variety of stakeholders
ranging from managers who aren't really
intimately involved in the codebase who
might not be sure what's going on they
might be another tier above another
manager things like that programmers who
are basically shunted around between
projects and who basically fix messes so
I've got a friend in Victoria and he's
basically one of these he goes between
jeffer projects he's got to figure out
what the projects about get the work
done and then get out because well he's
the valuable guy and they don't want to
waste them on all the small projects
then there's the new developers who are
unsure of how a project is actually
being done what are the protocols and
procedures how do you how do you say
checking code things like that as well
as there's other kinds of stakeholders
we're not necessarily very code driven
such as investors or people try
acquisition a company they might be
interested in what underlying software
development processes were being
followed during the development of that
project within that company that they're
interested in purchasing and as well as
there's ISO 9000 where you want to
document your software you want to get
the certification it's a big pain and
you don't really have a lot to work with
so those are the main stakeholders who
might be interested in this kind of
recovery thank you for asking could
figure was thank you okay so one example
that a manager might have is they might
propose a process they might propose it
as a mixture of workflows over time and
then when they recover this process they
can go ahead and actually see if it
matches their proposed process so they
could look at the different they could
look at the similarities and differences
between the processes they recovered and
the proposed and then they could
investigate further what those
differences actually were why weren't
their expectations met they could just
be straight up wrong but it'd be
interesting to know so that's one
potential use so how do we get this kind
of information how do we figure out
what's going on well we could ask the
developers we could ask the people
inherently involved but there's issues
there you might not have access to them
they might not be around anymore I
basically talking to developers I think
frankly annoys many of them especially
if it's not really important to them and
it also takes up a lot of time so if you
are not going to interview developers a
lot how are you going to get your
information well we could rely on
software repositories and the data left
behind we could try to summarize this in
a kind of unified process manner where
we basically break down a lot of the
information events here into the
different disciplines such as business
modeling requirements design
implementation and then we can look at
how these things change over time and
what events relate to these different
disciplines and workflows so
I'm now going to cover a little bit of
previous work and related research to
this to our work so in terms of mining
software posit orgastic processes I
Israel her as a tall they looked at the
distributions of say metrics over time
things like McCabe cyclomatic complexity
and other things as and a lot of code
metrics and they looked at many many
many open-source projects and they found
a wide variety of distributions most of
which were log normal double paretto
things like that which were certain
nasty Exponential's and they also found
that many of these metrics correlated
very heavily with lines of code there
was a this laws of software evolution by
Manny laymen and then people tried to
take his laws of software evolution and
either validate them such as in turski
or invalidate them in some cases as in
two and Godfrey weren't too and Godfrey
found that I think was the ninth lost
software evolution that said that the
growth would be sublinear due to
complexity they found in lengths colonel
at least due to copy and pasting drivers
that the growth of the Linux kernel was
super linear so it was a little bit
above leaner other work we rely upon is
business processes this is really just
another kind of process it's a little
too formal for say information work and
development but we rely on it
nonetheless so van der waals basically
would pose a business process as either
a finite state machine ER is petri net
where you push a token through say
finite state machine then there's we
rely on a wide variety of analysis a
little bit of social network analysis
such as work by bird at all as well as
statistics some natural language
processing mostly at the level of
counting words and doing topics we also
use machine learning to do
classification we rely heavily on time
series as the unified process diagram
does as well so this work comes out of
work by van der elst on process mining
where he would monitor a live business
process like buying chicken McNuggets at
McDonald's or setting up insurance
clients things like that
would monitor and measure the process
and then they'd formalize it either as
pietranera finite state machine cook at
all took that further and they applied
this to software so they told the
process they modified the process to
actually get more information so they
could observe it and extract these these
petri nets and finite state machine
representations of the process so our
approach is a little bit different it's
the mining software repositories
approach where we take the information
left behind and then we analyze that
after the fact without access to the
process itself without tooling the
process to get more information and we
try to get things like statistics the
underlying distribution of effort /
discipline and other things out of that
so that's really what process recovery
is about and again what we're going to
try to do is we're going to try to
summarize the information extracted from
those repositories in a unified process
kind of manner mostly because it's been
used in software engineering textbooks
to explain that we do a bunch of things
at the same time and software
development but we might have different
proportions of these of these
disciplines at different times so you
might not be doing a lot of requirements
later on unless you're adding new
features things like that sorry
what what's this oh it's it's all right
i think it was descriptive trying to
explain what was what you'd probably see
and then how does this handle hartville
premise like office is made of
six different projects they're all
synced together
and each one might have its own son face
this one but they're all kind of unified
into a bowl well I think you could have
multiple views so you can do your sub
projects as separate ones of these and
then you can have an aggregate view
where this stuff would probably be
thrown away because it no longer sings
but it very least you have the
proportion of effort so I'll get into
that later but I think it can be applied
and you don't need to apply it to the
whole thing it can be applied the sub
views
so I'll get into that
other work we heavily rely on is the
whole mining software repositories field
where basically mine repositories like
version control and other repositories
in order to get information about what
was going on in a project at a certain
amount at a certain time and oftentimes
this research does certain things like
try to predict faults and also expertise
basically like who would be an expert in
certain part of the project based upon
their past history so in this in this
work we rely mainly on three software
repositories we rely on discussion and
mailing lists we rely on bugs in the bug
tracker and we rely on version control
systems and the revisions to source code
and other files in those repositories so
just a quick overview of what mailing
list archive sins are consisting of so
basically mailing lists are often topic
driven some our user base some our
development based some have a different
topic like off-topic discussions and
they're basically discussions between
different people and these discussions
occur over time and these discussions
often reference what other people have
said and sometimes reference documents
they also have a bunch of metadata in
the header and they have big natural
language text in the body and this stuff
can actually reference other things so
it's oftentimes quite difficult to parse
the body because you usually need
something like natural language
processing or some kind of way of
understanding it followed by that would
be bug trackers which share some
similarities but i'd say the main
difference between say mailing lists the
bug tracker is that you have a bug ID
they've named them so not only do you
have a subject you've named basically
the whole discussion itself with a bug
ID and they're sort of like mailing
lists but usually different software
usually a little bit different but you
still have this discussion between
people about what to do referencing
artifacts and that all occurs over time
then we have the version control system
where we have authors over time making
commits to the codebase these commits
are composed of revisions these
revisions basically are changes to
separate kinds of files like builder
configuration scripts so
x documentation sometimes the actual
test of time source code so those are
the three main repositories we rely upon
to extract information at least in this
study you don't if you had a
documentation repository yet any other
information might be useful so other
other work we heavily rely upon our
source code metrics whether they're
straight source code whether their
evolution metrics such as like
information about the deltas or say
coupling metrics where you measure how
much files change together other work we
heavily rely on is a topic and concept
analysis so Pasha Vanek and Marcus
heavily used LSI and somewhat lda to
figure out what entities are associated
with certain concepts so a lot of this
was unsupervised and automatic where
these topics whether extract from source
code or natural language text would be
extracted from the repository and then
others such as lukens linstead and
maleic and handle would actually use lda
to apply it to natural language text
whether it was in the version control
commit comments or it was in the bug bug
repositories so lukens actually had an
interesting paper where they would use
lda on the bug on the bug tracker in
order to find in order to query for
template bugs so you provide a template
of what your bugs are looks like and
then you ask the bug tracker and it
comes up with a similar document so it
was document retrieval okay other stuff
we also rely upon is quality related on
functional requirements so Cleland Huang
has published a lot on mining NF ours
from source code and requirements
documents and Ernst Neil Aaron's teza
also published on just basically mining
these quality related non-functional
requirements from mailing lists
histories and version control histories
ok so that was a lot of the work that
that we rely upon in this
sorry about its length but let's get
down to the brass tacks of software
process recovery itself so we rely on
sub singles for software process
recovery we rely on information
extracted from version control systems
and things like this in this case of
release patterns what we do is we take
the revisions of the version control
system over time we basically partition
by file type so if it's a change to a
source code we suggest as a source coder
implementation revision it's changed to
your benchmarks to your unit tests
anything like that we say it's a test
revision if it's changed to your build
files ought to make auto conf and your
project files it's a build change and if
it's a change to your user documentation
or your developer documentation it's
recording the repository we suggest as a
documentation change now this doesn't
sound that useful but it actually is
useful once you a great it enlarged
especially with respect to events like a
release so we found was then certain
projects like say MySQL if you looked at
these signals across release time you
could get a general behavior that
behavior was actually consistent across
the release type so minor releases in
MySQL would look the same they'd have
the same kind of behavior around release
time for source code they might have a
lot of changes before and then it would
taper off after wear something like
postgresql did more of a freeze where
they would have no real source code
changes maybe a bunch of test changes
and minor build changes before release
then afterwards they'd have a huge spike
in source code changes because they'd
integrate all that cool stuff they were
working on which they couldn't have
integrated before the freeze so you
could see some kind of behaviors
especially process related behaviors
based upon these four signals in a very
simple manner eventually this story
about postgres how do you
was that story derived from straight
from
these kinds of diagrams or are you using
some of your own knowledge about how
software development works press
releases to embellish that story Robin
or is that so it was it was based upon
the data but also in order to see it I
guess you couldn't know that freezes the
curve so I saw it I thought it reads
occurred
you're being asked them whether I didn't
ask for something out yes
so the usefulness of this is just
relatively simple that's basically
partitioning by file type and you get
these four different signals suggesting
what kind of behavior is happening and
you can do neat things like look at the
correlation between the tests and source
code you could ask things like are we
doing test first things like that let's
see whether they give you more
interesting signals or are these before
that were the best ones in this study we
only did these four but if you have and
this was on file type so you could also
split on author because authors are
pretty heavily loaded especially an open
source projects where you have the top
three offers are really responsible for
everything
so if you would if you had separate if
you'd subsequently by authors might give
you more I didn't finish eighth between
source code and that's good well these
don't have to be straight of partitions
they can overlap but you can just say
anything that's just sodas on sirs it's
it's up to I guess how do you identify
this code oh so in Perl you look for dot
P files oh the quick way the dirty way
which far as no supervision is dangerous
it's look for tests but in say something
like a database system there's a lot of
things which are tests that are not test
code and especially in say a package
like are there would be a lot of cases
where tests would be actually code so
you got to be a little bit careful with
test code and we'll see you're relying
on the idioms that the programmers use
in order to identify what parts of
syringes so it's pretty project succeed
he end language this
so basically for this I had a bunch of
language specific tests
so like got T for Pearl benchmark and
there's a few others so the problem test
is there all the different kinds of
testing like regression tests and
benchmarks it still be considered tests
lie a lot
and in a database system benchmarks are
really
so if you got a performance-oriented
project you might have to be a bit more
specific over the desk did you have a
practitioner at if you like the
different types of tests to see if it
was any different behavior like unit
test versus we know you're making me
feel stupid
so this is just a quick example applying
to sqlite over time so 2001-2010 you can
see there's lots of source code
revisions there's a bunch of test
revisions there's hardly any
documentation revisions and there's a
couple build revisions so this is just a
concrete view of the source test build
documentation revisions the next thing
we did was a large a study of the large
changes in inversion control systems and
we basically categorize them with the
three Swanson maintenance classification
so we manually looked at them across I
think 18 open source projects it was top
1% in size so size of lines changed what
was interesting was for the large
changes that the vast majority weren't
really that Swanson orientated they
weren't really maintenance oriented they
were implementation so some people would
suggest an implementation would belong
in adaptive but these were explicitly
implementation like lots of times large
merges from another project a totally
new feature things like that we also
found that while the Swanson maintenance
classifications weren't really version
control specific we were dealing with
version control so we had to deal with
things like copyright changes legal
changes comment changes things like that
stuff then it never would change the
execution of the code but existed
nonetheless and so we applied it to many
projects and not all projects were
consistent I guess relevant to hear the
Sandberg project which is basically
Linux version of the windows network
file system they had a ton of adaptive
changes because they had to adapt a lot
to anything that changed in the windows
file system so some were more consistent
like fire bird which is a database
system I was pretty consistent across
everything
no bugs evolution um no big bugs know
like hundred line bugs yeah it's pretty
Oh like what's think so beginning you
talked about applications but you what's
the application for this diagram oh this
diagram is to show you sort of what
exists
so we took the previous information the
manuals and we check to see if we could
plan she learns automatically classify
the changes what's the user like it
who's the user is looking at this and
what is there okay so the first user
would be the researcher who who learns
they shouldn't throw away the big
outliers sure it's big outliers can
change so that's important the second
user would be more of an end-user with
the previous data
where this data would be used to train a
learner which would automatically
classify their changes
what personally hope cheap I was not
even what about a human well they'd at
least get to see an overview of what the
changes were thought to me so you could
use the learner to tag a change with dr.
correct and before they look at the
change they already see it's been tagged
with the definite corrected this would
allow wearing loud and scroll through
changes inside I only want to see the
bug fixes or all of the changes or what
were the last set of license
all right how difficult is it to train
in order to do that it seems like
deciding between whether it changes like
adaptive effective maybe like movie
oh so we did single single classes here
and we learned a hard lesson that this
is software categorization is not so
hard in the past so you want to use a
multi label
so that was the what features did you oh
the features were they were actually
really interested they were file type
author the text in the change commit I
think that was about it and what we
found was that you could throw away all
the files changed and keep only the
author or you could keep all the files
changed and throw away the author there
was so heavy a correlation and shared
information between those two that you
know you could choose one or the other
the author was very very important to
determinate well this was which suggests
that in some project rules yeah in some
projects that certain authors where you
know few hats how do you validate
oh we couldn't really validate too well
that we got the labels right in the
manual labeling where we went through me
label so me and Daniel Germany did look
at each other's labeling there's we
didn't ask so there you go to developer
this weekend's really like randomly
sampled or something for the automatic
lately
so we labeled a bunch and then we trying
to learners and then we try to learn
using
validation to see how well they did
against you
and they didn't do super great they were
like area under the ROC curve
I guess it's easier to think about it as
letter grade
some hideous okay
or six revealing
where it's point five additi here it's a
d
okay so then the other work we used were
developer topics and so what the
developer topics were is we took the
changelog comments and we push them
through a unsupervised topic analysis
engine like LSI or Lda and then we got
the topics out so we say lda give us 20
topics for this input text and gives us
20 topics these topics are basically
word distributions so basically counsel
words which isn't there really that
useful so what we did is we applied it
per month and then we look to see if any
of the topics reoccurred in the in the
consecutive months and if I what we
found was most topics don't reoccur
about 80% don't reoccur they're very
specific to that month sometimes the
topics would mention even a bug number
and it would be a bunch of documents a
bunch of changes related to that one bug
but it wouldn't occur in the next month
whereas there was some topics which
occurred across time and we looked at
these big long topics because they were
sort of interesting and we found that
they seemed to deal with sorry did yes
okay can you send the colors sorry okay
so something so gray is never repeat not
gray is does
okay i want to lift the boxes the bar
each box is a topic and if you had a PDF
viewer you could zoom in you can see the
words the top 10 words in that topic in
bed and so it's technically like the
zoomable graphic so this sort of
illustrates how fundamentally annoying
they output from say LS IRL da is
because these are the top 10 words it
will give you mad anymore identify like
you've got this big brown box but being
okay like same is it what is saving I
got it was the same 10 words no will be
nothing right so we have a threshold
like
Oh what are some boxes wider than other
like this box yeah or the boxes in the
lighter brown there's some are never on
some are wider than the gray boxes and
say okay because um if they if the topic
purrs in the next time when we joined
the box so this box the curds from 2004
july two thousand six months that one
big us yeah so that's a topic let's
stand along time facing a lot more words
for that topic and you are fairly the
great hunters well it's a lot of topics
joined together over time so these were
self-similar these were topics that were
similar to each other join together and
i think this one was correctness story
so laud the words dealt with bugs and
put fixing
and so based upon that observation we
felt well this diagram itself it's
really not that useful until we
interpret the topics right like right
now this is just some giant matrix right
it's not really that fun and so what we
tried to do is we tried to label the
topics and we had one interesting method
which was unsupervised where we provided
a dictionary of software engineering
terms related to non-functional
requirements like portability or say
reliability and then if a topic contain
any of these terms we just labeled it
with the concept itself portability or
reliability and we had five NF ours that
we labeled the topics with and this
allowed us to produce similar diagram
but with labels so this one was
maintainability that one was portability
and there also was there were topics
that dealt with more than one issue so
they'll be maintained a building
portability things like that or anything
like that not specifically that
but what was interesting was that lots
of the repeating topics were actually
related to non functional parts so they
were issues that crossed up a lot of
other projects issues like performance
maintainability portability
functionality efficiency and by using a
very simple dictionary based upon mining
ISO 9000 126 which is software quality
standards something or other I don't
remember they had a bunch of words in
there we stole those words put them into
this dictionaries threw it at this
worked out then we also tried well let's
use wordnet a word that was interesting
it had similar performance but wordnet
would include neat little words so for
things like efficiency it include
theater the reason why the word net
would include theater is because
performance and theater go together in
English language but for software it's
not really that meaningful so we felt
it'd be really nice having like a
software engineering wordnet where it
was more domain-specific and then
underneath that having a domain-specific
word where'd that would be cool to like
for databases there's these topics for a
similarly to you study where you were
looking at
types of changes
the lawyers changes the project where
you said you can probably just say that
guy makes a lot of evenings
could you do the same thing this guy
feel responsible efficiency so we didn't
do that but it'd be pretty simple to go
through the files or offer its
corresponding annotations and
okay so we had the labeled topics which
would what was also need is these topics
are related to documents so when we get
this topic it's back related to the
documents so basically what lda tried to
do they tried to say hey look you can
press these documents you gave me by
these mixture models of topics and via
that you also know which documents
relate to which topics thus you know
given this topic what documents are
related so you can use that to tag
documents as well okay so we did a we
did a bunch of work which didn't really
seem all that coherent but we had the
string it together so what we really
tried to do was we tried to take all
that previous work we tried to integrate
it in order to take this theoretical
diagram of what software process was and
produce a practical version of it where
we took those previous signals those
previous events and informations that
are information that our tag and we
produce a practical view of it based on
aggregating those so as an example we
had the unified process requirement
signal so we had a requirements based
word bag so basically that dictionaries
that I mentioned before we gripped
through three repositories version
control bugs and mailing list and then
we also looked for the NFR as we were
able to grab such as usability and
functionality so this was open source
code we weren't really sure where
requirements were discussed for the most
part in many cases open source projects
don't really have a lot of requirements
other than clone that other project so
sometimes the requirements already
implicit yeah and sometimes they have
external requirements documents so we
suggested that the u.p requirements view
the requirements signal would be this
mixture model of these and in this case
we just have coefficients of one so it's
a summation so what this is is this
basically the events that are related to
requirements over time pulled from three
repositories and we haven't done any any
kind of real mixing of it other than
submitting the events
and I'm not saying this is it hard and
fast I think if you had a project and
you knew that say you actually had a
documentation repository where
requirements documentation was or you
had story cards and yet it signal where
you knew how many story cards you had
over time created remove things like
that well you'd want to include that in
the requirement signal so we just we had
to do something that we tried to produce
something that would look like the
unified process model on something that
wasn't necessarily unified process
because their purpose with using the
unified process diagram was to
communicate was at least a first step to
show that well this could be done in a
certain manner 2001 yes right what is it
what happened
okay I think this one is freebsd and in
2001 i crept around because I was
worried about that this fight because if
it's not performance related relevant so
there actually was performance related
events occurring at it and one of them
was they were trying to meet up with
single UNIX specification version two so
they're trying to conform to that
external requirements document they were
mentioning that in the version control
another reason requirements got ticked
up was in terms of one of the
requirements words i think was
definition and they were converting to
GCC 2.96 at the time and they mentioned
that they're changing function
definitions so that's probably the
majority of the peak but there was
requirements related stuff there so the
design signal looks pretty well similar
to this one and at least it Peaks up in
the design signal so this isn't
necessarily very accurate yeah you
follow these projects everywhere or was
Oh was like like let's say that I didn't
know anything and I'm like dude there's
a spike here well what would I do to try
to figure out so good what actually was
going on so I'm full disclosure to find
what was going on this bike I use awk I
said walk on these files in csv files
which we needs two dates grab me those
and then I use grep Michael grep here's
my requirements document or my
requirements dictionary grep anything
that matches that so pipe the hawk stuff
and rep and then I looked up what was
there ok so you could do it with that
external yeah so if like actually
then yes
it seems that when the projects are
smaller like
a spike might still exist whereas in two
thousand why if you show it look do you
normalize per quarter looks like this if
I don't know I didn't and I mention it
in the paper that it's based on that
it's something you might want to do
because you're right there's very little
here and there's X blotto and in terms
of version control it's pretty well that
there's a ton of work over here very
little done over there so you do want to
if you're looking at a specific time
period you might want to normalize for
that time period
and you might also want normalize this
up based on size
it's because each question might be you
might want to normalize versus the
number of check-ins versus the number
people
everyone
so there's definitely multiple ways of
doing the normalization and so I don't
have any part invest
you should do what you're looking
so if I was to give this to an end user
like a manager they'd have all these
coefficients which they could fiddle
with and potentially see what they want
to see but also potentially see what's
there so there is that balance because
these days after the release
at these signals by within sight
I
basically for validating this it was two
case studies freebsd and sqlite forget
it and basically i was looking at most
of so I didn't do negative validation
where what didn't happen did it happen
things like that was most adjusted
studies part of the large behaviors
physically
so there's definitely a lot more
validation more communities but I think
what was neat about it was that we
showed that we could try to derive some
kind of process view I would have the
events that occurred and I don't think
the unified process is really all that
valid for every project especially a lot
of the open source projects you probably
want to show some more concrete signals
as well like I think the build signal is
very important for a seat project is
every time you add a dot C file well
you're probably going to change the make
file or the dev file or one of those
how do you choose the projects that you
decided to look at
so I had freebsd because i had done
dividing challenge and it was a long
live project it's feel like for
something as well
and I just awesome extractors I was only
guy who actually had most of Escalades
information
so it was basically two case studies of
long-lived projects which were
previously is popular sqlite so if you
had to let's say that like you could
snap your fingers right now and get the
data for another purpose or project but
would be one that given what you know
about it with the good ones who look at
you think might use after you I'm not
gonna answer you in fact process one but
I use apache next step this because
everybody looks it actually well because
Apache is very explicit but with their
processes and if I'm doing pasta salad
ation obviously the next step is to
compare you know we said we did this
with what we did so like this stuff is
pretty well baby steps where it's the
real stuff across every needs a lot
about this
but a lot of people weren't really up to
this point so this is what I got a
thesis oh
Pokiri the implementation signal is much
more concrete I took the source code
changes and I said they were
implementation changes they might have
been maintenance changes but the very
least it was a very concrete signal very
direct the testing signal is more
interesting because i took the testing
changes along with portability changes
which we can argue about and the
efficiency changes because it might be
benchmarking regression tests especially
for something like freebsd or SQL Lite
where they care about performance and I
also took reliability changes because a
lot of those sometimes when you do a fix
you might do a test so this is the most
concrete of the signals and these ones i
would say have less power but they might
be relevant in terms of regression tests
and performance testing and this
produces the u.p testing signal what's
your right error bars incentive you have
some sir doing several different kinds
of analysis that each
possibility for error over oxidation and
by merging them together is there a
sense that you actually could be
in other words it better but more clear
if you do like a bandit what the trend
could be over time as opposed to
individual spikes which I should
probably articulate
I don't think you can truly get error
until you have a crunk read you of
what's going on Jan Oracle canoe
everything then you know but if you
don't know
surterre so in that case I think you
rely on the confidence of those people
who have expertise
so it's serve part
so that's that's a big promises how to
do it how did the sleigh it
interested in that
your source signals have
standard deviations but
seems to have the lower
yeah and
and it it's interesting to me that they
are not mutually supportive
that what that suggesting is that there
is
I degree of correlation between those
four sourcing
if we go back to the topics we could see
that certain topics were prevalent for
different periods so I think this has to
do a lot with how software isn't about
everything at once
it's though what you're focusing on at
one time at least if you look at one
slice what are we doing right now we're
not doing everything chosen to do a
couple of
so that might be a kind of topic shift
right would you can
interesting citizen
yes should you pick signals that are
highly correlated or should you pick
singles that are literally not
correlated at all so you're getting some
sort of then you get a flat on
which is by definition absolutely you
don't have to you can you can look at
these signals and then you can look at
the signal sir Quran right so I believe
like the build signal is a really great
example
a lot of interesting information in for
certain comments and questions
especially see if they complain as a
bill change within the cave in
architecture change
SF inspector
real inside ball is this like new story
here
feel and certainly with these two
pictures turn
no explanation
maybe that comes back christmas day
earlier gather deeply contextualized on
this step
for these children
so I don't and I don't know if that's a
presentation problem or I don't have to
release itself n iterations see that's a
creepy diagram it's good test it let's
say Tucker police manager or
gave the chart for their project
but it's a which ones can and how actors
are they or how knowledgeable are there
without having to go to poke around yeah
and maybe there's another question
why is it interesting report on
a decade man history of this project
what what we expect to learn
doesn't need to be the whole project so
but it is I mean you're showing me the
hall pet sir it is what it is so you're
showing me this picture Fermi's and what
what is that
well I needed a way to express what
what's potentially the underlying
software development
view of it
and so we look at the original UK
diagram it start it actually the u.p
diagram has a whole lifetime line
they've got the inception and then
they've got
let's suppose the last phase from Peter
oh
so they have that so they've got the
whole so this was the first step in
trying to show well what would the hope
what would the lifetime
so dark
so there's definitely a lot of issues
with it and there's a lot more
validation and investigation and have
actually shown as well as in future work
dimension I really want to see
iterations are automatically
identifiable or what a during the
iteration bars would really tell you
okay so I re discuss the freebsd stuff
sorry it's together like that if you
have a particular issue presumably
a feature that gets discussed a lot on
gotcha which we had
this particular feature in sequel life
presumably that's coming up on user
lists then the developers are doing a
whole bunch of check-ins about that and
then the use of this is going back on
the user Lester knew the dead ones and
you know that their fourth to third
issue
that's going to kind of move through the
pipeline yeah but at least with the
smooshing you get to see in this
repository that was this and possibly
due to is it possible for three was this
so it might look flat even though you
know repository
so it's a multi repulsor review so it's
already multi-dimension signal total it
was how do we show we could do other
stuff
asking people how much the trust signal
constables like do you really want to
see the useless you do maybe it's very
important maybe actually a lot of dev
work Hutchinson accusers like rats kill
life developers don't really let a lot
of people on to the devil
so I had already explained this before
above the peak and so just to reiterate
it was the GCC 2.95 port and it was the
single user UNIX specification version
two conformance and so that caused this
peak in analysis and requirements at
least that's what I gripped out of there
and I'm wasn't really sure about testing
so we applied this to SQL Lite as well
and we looked an interesting peek at the
end which was across quite a few things
and so we see this big requirements peak
here if we look over here the
configuration management peak is
different a testing peak is different so
it's not necessarily the same event so
in terms of requirements this was really
interesting they went to their dot H
files and they they had requirements
jammed into the dot H file comments what
they did here is they actually took
those requirements out and they made a
formal requirements document very rare
and open source and also sort of strange
seeing as 2001 was over here and this
occurred in 2009 so later I went and
looked and look for why would you do
this and they basically wanted to have a
requirements document where anyone could
reimplement SQLite even though it is
public domain software so not even on
open-source licenses public domain like
you're free to take it no attribution
but what was interesting was is yeah
that was notice the requirements thing
was noticed and there was also another
requirement speak around here which was
interesting which was the sqlite3
discussion where they were referencing
SQL books to look at for say
implementations that be trees things
like that so at least in terms of some
of the peaks they panned out in terms of
what was in the repositories and that
was validated by a Aachen grip actually
grabs really nice in terms of ignoring
schemas so you can basically grep across
data without the schema getting in the
way so that actually has some value
so is SQLite so this led to issues of
observability so we discussed the
requirements we discussed the waiting's
we discuss things like that certain
signals were not as observable
particularly business modeling in
open-source sense not a lot of projects
have business modeling maybe evolution
had a little bit at the start in their
mailing list the mail client but that
was about it so not everything was
observable and that was one of the
issues so some common threads we
observed while going through all this
stuff was there as idioms and we could
rely on idioms whether their file naming
other kinds of naming behaviors use of
different kinds of files and this also
related to sort of a vocabulary within
the project kind of lexicon used
internally to a project which actually
had little shared vocabulary but of
those shared vocabulary we found that
many of the shared terms seem to relate
to non-functional requirements like
usability maintainability portability
and especially reliability and
correctness soon you could I don't know
maybe each card I hope it has has their
own number of different
dimensions be useful for like maybe a
newcomer to a project or something like
that with it just trying to having gone
through this just recently it for like
you know joining script or something
within a project understanding the
idioms or seeing examples are saying
like this is prevalent would be good I
think language management is sort of the
next sort of big butt oh yeah so let's
let's try to fortify you know this word
means this we're going to use this
hollow see a domain modeling yeah or the
reverse like I've encountered helps
where I know what word I used for a
concept and I'm trying to figure out
what we're to use for that concept
somewhere else it's a cute really tough
what a like cinnamon list like
understanding have a source Eco concepts
and have to stuff I've seen in the open
source will complete this form
so for future work we want to apply more
people in the team's orientated analysis
so imagine doing the Rupp v's / author
how would those change the unified
process views we extract how would those
change / author things like that we also
have to do a ton of validation work some
of which requires harassing people and
asking them is this really what happened
we also want to improve the accuracy of
some of these things and maybe do an
industrial case study excuse me we also
want to look into it eration
identification so basically I done some
machine learning in the past trying to
figure out is this release time or not
and it didn't really pan out that well
but with this new source of data it
might pan out down on it ICP they should
like identifying releases as this
research topic but it's unclear to be
what the real benefit of that is because
if it's in real time you can like ask
and if its retrospective you can get
super high accuracy and it releases
aren't that frequent you can just go
into the project page or something like
that so is is they're really worth
putting a lot of sort into identifying
releases maybe not releases but the pace
is within a release
if you can say that a certain phase is a
linear combination of the certain
disciplines or certain signals you
extract it then you can suggest how much
a certain time window is how much a
certain time that we know development is
related to that face so are we in a
freeze fits are we in a
testing dates are we in heavy
implementation
crystallized so those kinds of faces
would be theirs duplication
how much of all this could be replaced
with anthropologist hired by let's say
that their shadow them get all this
information to smoking
at writing a story right
super wack
I could what's the trade-off here well I
think definitely some of these tools
would be used by them or just
jewels for free no no no that very good
point but you're going to hot like you
terrible page just to be a historian
and fathers
so they birthday song help I'm talk
about with
but if you're say purchasing a company
who didn't hire
a lot of the stuff attack fans click
want to change the process where
gorgeous going to get nightstick
I definitely think so at least managing
playing having athletes language
shipments
the higher the hiring you know my
company that didn't
then you make the archaeologists
but the archaeologists means tools
yeah privileges well I would also say
this to other floods with an apology
which is all related to scale which is
an anthropologist a can't watch up in
the new the same time so they can't
really know what all the stories are
which you might be
particular story plus they also i don't
know i think they spend like 20 years
with some movie native tribe before
they're in their book so you find on one
wait 20 years if you have 15 years of
previous need you can read the book but
if back in 92 95 something when we know
what was going on and fall into said
well I'll get back to ya that might have
been at home as well so these tools
could help for
through makes you wonder if you will see
and you said you have an anthropologist
for two weeks of times could they help
you identify the relevant topics ahead
of time or identify the idioms that you
like enhanced
one of the reasons of topic analysis was
that's a shipping
so say you have a story card that you
have to fulfill and causes say a
performance regression that wasn't sorry
card but you got put out that fire so
you've gone all this long journey to
fulfill the story card and you end up
over there shipping
so the topic analysis is hoping would
maybe highlight what what's going on
Hitler Jack shaving involved what words
topics that occurred that were important
that may be the manager wouldn't know
about because like why didn't you guys
finish the story purpose
that's it why
ok so just quick summary of props its
recovery
lovely pet
so we've got our repositories that we
relied on at least for this study their
discussion lists are bug bug bug tracker
our version control systems and we
applied a wide variety of analysis
related from NFR related word word lists
from maintenance classes topic analysis
release patterns all that and then we
aggregated lots of those signals up into
a unified what we called the recovered
unified process views which was
basically a concrete version unified
process diagram and this stuff was
relevant to a wide variety of
stakeholders mostly those not inherently
involved with the code or those who are
just beginning in a project and not
really sure what's going on now I want
to go a little bit further about this
this is like awful selling point so how
do I think this is relevant to Microsoft
I think there's three main points so
internally for use integration in
existing products and how existing
products could actually help in the
future help this kind of analysis so for
internal processes I think one of the
issues is when you have the globally
distributed development you want to keep
tabs on things you don't always have
your manager in the same location things
like that you might have the proposed
process and at least maybe you can
validate what the underlying process was
and what the differences were so at
least in terms of like project dashboard
project timeline some of the stuff might
help and I don't doubt that you have
some of it that's weird okay another
thing would be to look at say a
successful project and try to see is
there actually a correlation between the
successful projects in terms of their
processes or teams and look at that and
see if there's any kind of consistency
across there
yep studying the software process is
there a relationship to how may be a
study business processes are there
lessons to be learned from management
schools on what good processes of life
or whether they correlate
ok so I was reading venerables workflow
processes where basically he wanted to
mine the processes and then refactor and
he used the formalism of petri nets so
it's trying to look at how that supply
and click applied that but it required a
lot of work a lot too so I think it is
possible for you some of the business
process work but a lot of the business
process work is very very fine grain and
would probably only be appropriate
software in very small domains at least
lightly like the bug bug tracker
oftentimes imposes a process so that's
one side effect of the software and so
you could look at that process and use
the business process for factoring in
order to approve well how can we get
nicer bug reports how can we get people
for bugs bite perhaps
so I think in some subsets in some
context we can use business process
stuff for software but in many cases the
very information work kind of thing so
we don't really have the very strict
States
I guess one thing to look into would be
is there any way to avoid the expertise
issue where you have non-expert
programmers and expert programmers
because a lot of the business process
refactoring is about parallelizing the
work and moving the documents between
different people who might not have a
lot of expertise in what's necessary
there so maybe some of that but I didn't
really go into that and my stuff and I
didn't really feel that the business
processes were all that appropriate to
say modeling an open source system maybe
some of the Apache stuff where they
claim to have very strict processes but
not in all cases and I think because
we're fundamentally information work
while developing we don't really have
this you know clear kind of staggered
stage to stage kind of development so
there's also various products that might
be amenable to having some of the
software process recovery integrated
into them whether for Microsoft or for
their end users so project dashboard and
visual studio 2010 might help some
signals might be useful like the stbd
stuff the source test build
documentation stuff might be useful just
to see is your current release similar
to your last release if they're not
similar why aren't they similar you go
and look there's also the word bag
analysis stuff which is very cheap to
apply relatively inaccurate but still
very cheap once you've got a dictionary
you can ship to other people and then
the topic analysis is sort of
interesting but it eventually becomes a
supervised method if you really want
very well labeled topics so that might
be a little bit hard and then the harder
stuff to apply would be anything that
requires end user interaction for
training our words and I don't think
that would really pan out and go very
far with end users because well I bet
everyone in this room has done
annotation and I don't think anyone here
likes it
okay so those were a couple things that
could be integrated in say project
dashboard project dashboard has some
interesting stuff in it that I really
like like the burndown charts the burn
rates backlogs these are things which
I'd want as signals when I'm looking at
or aggregating to produce the recovery
unified process views those are really
nice signals to have because there's a
very process-oriented they're usually
like requirements or store card based
what's getting done I think that's
really interesting and I be neat to have
a tab flow both ways get access to that
and vice versa so code book is
interesting and I think some of this
stuff could go in the code book so
imagine like a social view of the
recovery unified process views so you're
looking at one project you're looking at
a couple people involved who you're
connected with what does your aggregate
a network look like or what does one of
your buddies look like or has your one
buddy been mostly working and
portability related issues things like
that that kind of analysis so that might
be really neat
a small corpus like the techs produced
by an individual this is this
for like the auto lately
well with at least enough ours we have
shared terminology at least
so I think what the NFR is you can get
away with them with cross project across
individual
so you can get away with a lot of
training on the individuals
well I mean you end up with with just
little tiny spikes off of a hole out of
0 ants line and the further you go down
from in smaller and smaller groups of
people or in spawns olive in desert
in both cases your your bags of words
can't
and the signals are going because
you could have acted instead of doing
solution personally stacked bar
see if there is a topic that across
people or their suspect from one
person's little books from the other
people like red afterwards they lost a
cup and you can kind of see that
it's one person got involved maybe there
was
against that
yeah so I think you can get some really
neat interaction crafts out of this
even this stuff like seeing who's
working on implementation immediately
who's actually doing testing who's
committing build changes like this sucks
totally unsupervised and various
so I think that would be pretty and I
think you're right about the word bag
maybe some people don't use certain
terms you could also
anyway so I'm just saying there's
potential for directions
recovered by process used and at least
in the social setting I think would be
really interesting especially person
specific groups
ok here's the first
if
person i work on internationalization
and localization all the time that's our
job that's what we do together we will
never say those words
because their cancer because because
there they are the bubble that is around
we all need to talk so so
even though that's what we're doing
that's
yeah sunset cyclone internationalisation
true because buddies
it's going to be the seventh of wet
we're like a link to a page is often
much more descriptive of that page so
anybody who references you will probably
also use the word internationalization
just go genius games
they should talk to her and so if you
found links to you in other email
messages that you can figure out that
you were nationalisation person and
that's I'm a topic and then understand
what the domain
okay so then i'm going to cover what
basically sly
playing hard so one of the problems i
found was i couldn't estimate effort at
all at least with the open source stuff
there is no indication of time you had
lock but that doesn't necessarily say
how long they spend so you can take the
Big Brother approach and you could
actually record at least this might work
in companies where there's you know sort
of a lesser expectation of privacy but
it doesn't always happen like I
understand there's serious issues with
it but at the very least if you allowed
the the commits to be tagged with you
know time spent or effort spent things
like that and then maybe allowed the
developers to modify them just in case
you know like maybe left the computer on
in the yeah yeah so I'm I've done up not
quite this but a little bit of it and
what I found was interesting about
monitoring windows being opened was that
you really had to be aware of idle and
non idle time and different applications
probably had different idol x so I had
mine set the 30 seconds which would make
all my movie-watching not count cuz
movies are pretty long yeah yeah yeah I
didn't let me like sometimes when I'm
actually developing all go read it msdn
page moving around but it might be
relevant yeah yeah so that's also a
possibility like if you had a web
browser aware yeah so having some kind
of concrete measurement might be useful
but there's definite downsize
this it's still a possible is it a great
rest oh I think if you pop it I was a
holder about it it's not a couple the
max don't have is gonna go yeah so so
this goes back into the kinetics and
adding more metadata so something like
visual studio by you know more
information the structure the time
traceability related artifacts could
even go through all the web pages you
looked at which in some cases will not
be great but probably have to have a
delete button on some of those it's like
facebook facebook facebook facebook yeah
so there's there's possibilities adding
more information such that you could do
better tracking of certain things
certain things you're interested
especially structure a lot of the small
talk VCS is they cover structures so you
can actually see when structure changes
over time yeah like the architecture
yeah another thing that could be
improved would be so i'm not really sure
what you guys use for project
documentation I assume it's like word
and maybe you commit that somewhere I'm
not sure I don't know but the point is
is that one other thing that could help
would be the ability to have more
traceability between all these documents
so when you're writing up something and
it goes into a mail message or
referencing someone else if there is a
way to get better traceability out of
that and that could be enabled by it I
don't know better document repositories
better analysis of the documents put
into repositories things like that okay
so in conclusion we got software process
recovery which is the after the fact
recovery of software development
processes from the artifacts left behind
and this is exploitable by Microsoft
both internally and externally and I've
shown how Microsoft can
so improve the future at least in
getting some interesting signals out
such that you can better track your
project with some caveats okay thanks